things in the universe don't just shift
around
they also rotate and so what we're going
to do in this video is start to think
about rotations and rotational motion
and I'm intentionally continuing to spin
this because I find it
hypnotic but the question is well how do
we start to quantify these things
measure them and describe them so that
we can predict what will happen
well what if we introduce a notion of
angular displacement we have
displacement which is are a shift in
position but what if you have a change
in angle that seems like it would
describe something for example right
here my angle would be zero radians and
then if I move counterclockwise PI over
2 radians now my angle is PI over 2
so why not define going from the going
from there to there as an angular
displacement of PI over 2 radians and if
I were a displaced by PI over 2 again I
will go over here and never go negative
PI radians well that would be just like
that negative PI over 2 from there would
get me right over there that seems like
a fairly intuitive thing and you might
be saying why is positive
counterclockwise
and why is negative clockwise well that
just tends to be the conventions that we
use for angles so there you have it
we've already built our foundation for
describing rotational motion we can have
an idea of angular displacement angular
displacement which we can define more
formally just the way we just described
it we could say well look this is going
to be our change in angle so change in
Greek letter Delta and angle we use the
Greek letter theta which we've been
using since geometry or trigonometry
class and so our angular displacement
you can define as your final angle minus
your initial angle and we could say that
this is a vector quantity because you
can either go counterclockwise in which
case your this is going to be a positive
quantity or you could go clockwise in
which case this is going to be a
negative quantity well that's all nice
and fair but I know what some of you are
thinking it's nice to be able to see how
much your angle has changed but isn't it
much more interesting to also describe
how fast that angle is changing for
example here it's changing quite slowly
let's say it takes us three seconds to
have an angular displacement of two pi
one-mississippi two-mississippi
three-mississippi
that feels very different a lot slower
than if I did that in one second
one-mississippi two-mississippi so what
if we were to have something that would
describe our rate of change of angle
well we could borrow some terminology
that we've used in the past instead of
calling that velocity we could call that
angular velocity angular velocity and
how would you define that pause this
video think about that
well angular velocity you could just say
that is our change in angle over a
certain amount of time if I change two
pi radians in one second well that's
going to be a lot slower than if I
change two pi radians in half a second
and the letter we use for angular
velocity the convention is the Greek
letter Omega which looks like a fancy
lowercase W or at least this right over
here is the lowercase Omega which looks
like a fancy lowercase W which we use
for angular velocity and this too is a
vector quantity because it's measuring a
rate of another vector quantity and so
just to hit the point home just to
review it all make it all gel in your
mind angular displacement it's nothing
more than our change in angle if our
change in angle is counterclockwise like
this it's going to be positive so let's
say so an angular displacement we might
start here we don't always start at zero
radians so let's say we start at PI over
two an angular displacement of PI over
four would take us right over there an
angular displacement from there of
negative PI over two might take us right
over there and if we cared about angular
velocity-- if we said hey we are going
to go pi radians
every second well then that would be
like this it would be one second two
seconds three seconds four seconds if we
were to say we do two pi radians every
second then that would be twice as fast
in terms of angular velocity one
Mississippi two Mississippi three
Mississippi four Mississippi five
Mississippi so there you have it and in
the next few videos and in the practice
exercises on Khan Academy we will get
even more familiar with this side these
ideas and see how powerful they are for
describing rotational motion in the
universe